on part aux pays bas et aux pays bas il
ya un enseignant a été suspendu il est
mort de rire thibault déjà à l'avance il
a été suspendu c'est vrai pour une
raison prenant à dire les reporters de
dimanche nous la dévoile sur l'écran de
cette salle de classe hollandaise
apparaît soudain et oui des photos
pornographiques t ce professeur qui
regarde un site porno qui ne semble pas
se rendre compte que son ordinateur est
relié au vidéoprojecteur le prof sera
viré de son collège
mais les élèves eux manifestent pour
qu'il soit réintégré bien grave dit il
c'est juste une erreur de sa part une
erreur que les élèves comme est
peut-être de temps en temps le prof lui
vient de décider de prendre sa retraite
anticipée tout seul chez lui il pourra
donc que m toutes les horreurs qu'il
veut c'est horrible caisse très haute
pour que non vous voir écoutez moi bien
ce prof
oui mes enfants auraient été dans sa
classe les bains mais j'aurais hurler au
scandale j'aurais voulu qu'on jette ses
entrailles à la taille et madame c'est
bien ce que vous êtes pour des
raveonettes alors attention je vais
quand même mettre un petit bémol puisque
selon la presse
oui attendez je vous explique pour
quelles raisons au tibet selon la presse
locale ce professeur pourrait avoir été
victime d'une mauvaise blague je vous
explique attendait un élève lui aurait
demandé de regarder sur des moteurs de
recherche interne dans le sens n'est pas
pornographique en néerlandais mail est
en anglais lac résultats il s'affiche ce
qui s'affiche
et donc voilà donc ce serait peut-être
une mauvaise blague qui aurait fait que
d'où le soutien des élèves
la direction de l'école ordonné une
enquête interne mais à d'ores et déjà
annoncé que cela ne changerait rien au
principe d'une sanction de l'enseignant
alors attendez d'en mais si c'est une
erreur et si c'est un coup monté de la
part des élèves là évidemment moi je
prend la défense du prof où es-tu
maarten je me je me range du côté du
prof n'est plus dans le reportage et que
simplement il est en cours et il fait
ses petites affaires
évidemment qu'il est viré dans la
seconde évidemment qu'on ne manifeste
pas pour le retour de cette crise passe
aujourd'hui ça normal
les filles elles vous parle de sexe en
permanence toute la journée et elle
s'imagine que leurs enfants de 14 15 16
ans ils ont jamais rien vu eux mêmes
ivoiriens
je suis sérieux de course est arrimée
fallu tout le monde en même temps michel
pardonnez-moi mais la hausse est un
professeur dont qui les autorise les
dépositaires d'une autorité
oui on est dans une salle de classe il
ya quand même deux facteurs qu'il faut
que normalement à aucun moment ils
devraient soumah d'image il ne décide
pas de projeter des images pornos sur
l'écran il se plante et il ya des images
pornos qui s'affiche
honnêtement ce le premier site visité au
monde c'est le site porno bouilhou porn
qui est quand même merde et qu'elle en
perd deux j'en fais ton petit fils et
l'art est difficile en psy pour le pape
et un autre pour monsieur droit de
réponse à mr chose y'a pas de mal à se
faire du bien
première chaîne seconde chose jean
michel ne me contredira pas les seniors
et les nouvelles technologies
il peut y avoir problème soucis donc ce
n'est pas de sa faute 1
il a pu être piégé et 2 si jamais par
mégarde il a appuyé sur le bouton
rétroprojecteur bam sa part pas mais
match de foot avec ce modèle excusez moi
mais pardonnez moi mais même s'il a un
temps de break un temps mort dans sa
classe pendant que les élèves font un
contrôle ou je ne sais quoi est ce que
c'est vraiment le moment à gérer on a
regardé il ya il ya quelques temps dans
la même émission
on a montré que l'âge des premiers
rapports sexuels chez les petits
français
ils étaient 17
de toute façon les enfants les
infobulles le réintégrer y reviennent
raison il
les enfants adorent aller sur des sites
de ce genre de débilités battue me
reconnais minutes
non mais on n'est pas en train de dire
que personne n'a jamais bien grand mot
ici autour de sa taille on dit je ne
suis pas sûr c'est pas très grand
parce que vous en pensez avec le hashtag
sécu des lt est ce que comme jean michel
cohen c'est pas grave il a fait une
erreur on bien comme ludivine retory il
vous voulez mettre les entrailles de
solutions voilà très bien